Chris Hemsworth is one of those rare actors
who can do it all.
The Australian star clearly excels in action
films, considering he's the mighty Thor of
the Avengers in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
But he can also handle fantasy, comedy, drama,
and even horror.
This kind of versatility means that Hemsworth
is regularly on set, and all those long hours
can make even the biggest movie stars a little
loopy.
Well, the results have been caught on film.
Here are some of the best Chris Hemsworth
bloopers.
Juggling act
Mjolnir, Thor's mighty hammer, is unmovable
by pretty much everyone except the God of
Thunder himself.
It's probably the most famous object in Norse
mythology, and certainly the most famous tool
in comics this side of Captain America's shield
or Batman's utility belt.
Of course, the hammer Hemsworth carries around
in all the Marvel films is just a lightweight
prop.
And apparently, he can toss it around and
juggle it quite easily.
Okay, maybe not easily.
Joke-busters
Before the cameras roll, actors carefully
memorize their lines.
Preparation is important for a good performance,
of course.
But familiarization with the material is critical
in comedies — if actors don't know what's
coming, they're liable to laugh and ruin takes.
Now imagine how tricky it gets once everyone
is improvising on the spot.
Take the 2016 Ghostbusters, for example, when
Hemsworth had to describe why he likes hot
dogs:
"It contains all two food groups…"
"Dogs and buns… (laughs) sorry."
Director Paul Feig encourages
actors to try out ideas that pop into their
heads during filming, and even throws out
suggestions himself.
But sometimes, when a joke is brand new, it's
hard to deliver it with a straight face.
"I slept through a fire once.
Didn't even smell it."
"It was in your house?"
"Yeah."
"The whole house burned down around me."
"Yeah, f---!"
And once a bad case of the giggles has set
in, there may be no coming back from it.
"The fire was in your house?"
"Yeah.
And the whole house went down.
F---, it upsets me now! (laughs)"
Just say it
Certain scenes in Thor: The Dark World between
Hemsworth and Natalie Portman's character,
Jane Foster, are tender and emotionally powerful.
Well...they were supposed to be.
"But I do know this…"
"Know what?"
"I know…"
"That what?"
Come on, Thor, just tell her how you feel.
"Jane, I don't know what happened or where
you were…"
Huntsman holdups
Hemsworth plays the the title role in the
Huntsman films, the action-packed adaptations
of the Snow White folktale, collected and
popularized by the Brothers Grimm in 19th
century Germany.
The films actually take place long before
that — they have a strong Medieval, fairy
tale vibe.
At any rate, it's long before the dawn of
mechanical flight.
Which means Hemsworth had to put the acting
on pause whenever filming was interrupted
by scene-stealing airplanes.
But planes weren't the only things that held
up production.
Unfortunately, there was one on-set diva who
wanted nothing to do with poor Hemsworth.
And then there were those moments where he
had no one to blame but himself.
"Hang on… the worst-paced acting ever."
Do a little dance
What if you witnessed one of the strongest
and most unbreakable objects on the planet
crack in half and reveal itself for what it
truly is — some flimsy little objects glued
together?
Let's just say, a little dancing solves most
problems.
Cape gone wild
The three most defining characteristics of
Thor are the powerful hammer in his hand,
that long blond hair, and his red cape that
ripples in the wind behind him.
Well, two out of three ain't bad.
Because on the set of this standalone Thor
film, Hemsworth's most temperamental co-star
was… that cape.
In addition to the cape issues on the Dark
World set, it apparently wasn't clear to some
people whether certain scenes had finished
filming or not...
"I believe you were and you weren't."
"What the hell's this?
We're still going!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!